Hmm,
I would like to move onto discussing
myths.
This is so interesting.
So I would just say one more thing
because I,
if you,
uh,
if you talk to these people about how we
can reconstruct homosexuals,
I mean,
can you send,
can you send them to a straight camp?
I mean all of them would say that's
horrible,
but if you ask about how can you
deconstruct and then reconstruct boys
and their masculinity,
all of them are aboard.
So.
Yeah.
So,
so it's,
it's a very inconsistent.
Well,
I mean,
one of the things I complained about
last year with regards to this build cc
see legislation in Canada,
as I said,
look,
you're instantiating a social
constructionist view of gender,
gender,
expression,
sexual proclivity,
all of these things into the law.
Okay?
So it's socially constructed.
Okay.
So wake up.
The Conservatives who have been,
uh,
opposing homosexuality for the last
hundred years have used nothing but
social constructionist arguments.
They basically say,
well,
if it's socially constructed or an
individual choice,
which is,
by the way,
now it's stantiating into Canadian law,
then why the hell can't you just be
reeducated out of it?
Or just drop it if it's just an
individual choice.
Well,
I tried to say you're,
yeah,
you're playing with fire the fire that
will consume you.
Okay.
But you know,
okay,
nobody,
nobody.
No,
I shouldn't say nobody.
These arguments are,
these arguments are subtle and,
and they're not easy to follow.
And so,
and the problem is,
is that the consequences of producing
legislation like that unfold over
decades,
not minutes.
Yeah.
So I don't know.
Did you see what happened at Wilfrid
laurier university in Canada last week,
two weeks ago?
Lindsay Shepherd.
Does that ring a bell?
I listened to the conversation.
She recorded.
Yeah.
So in Canada now,
three things are happening.
The first is,
despite the fact that I predicted this
and that the only reason my reputation
was ever let's say tarnished,
was because I predicted that this was
going to happen.
I'm still being vilified by people who,
even,
who,
who are admitting nonetheless,
that what happened at Wilford Laurey was
reprehensible.
Okay?
So that's one thing.
The second thing is the people that
Laurie,
who used,
who accused Lynsay of breaking the
Canadian federal and provincial laws are
being accused of misinterpreting those
laws,
which they aren't as far as I'm
concerned,
but that enables people to save face.
And third and most a fair number of
faculty members and public commentators
are claiming that Ramboo,
Kana and pim lot and Joel,
who were the interlocutors in the
inquisition are the true victims,
but really?
Oh absolutely.
Because now,
now that people have been.
Well,
first of all,
they were only standing up for trans
rights and second,
well because they've been the target of
substantial criticism,
let's say like overwhelming,
punishing,
brutal criticism on ending for weeks
while they're that they're now victims
because that's just not fair.
And so when the president could Wilfrid
laurier university apologized to lynsay
shepherd,
she also said,
but you know,
I also feel,
I also feel that what has happened to
the faculty members in the aftermath of
this faculty members and administrators
was also raw.
So like,
it's that typical thing.
You know,
you see this when kids get bullied in
schools.
Now is that the idiot
interveners and they're and they're
blind.
Humanitarian impulse is bringing the
bully and the victim into the
principal's office to discuss it,
assuming equal,
equal causal,
what would you call it?
Responsibility on the part of the victim
and the perpetrator,
and they think that,
well,
if they just had a nice talk about it,
then
we could be settled.
Not understanding at all that the bully
who's,
let's say one of these,
one in 100 Predator types,
it's just going to stand on the outside
of the school ground and wait for the
victim to come by and just pound the
hell out of him because that's how
bullies work.
It's like,
well,
we could settle it like reasonable
people.
And he's like,
yeah,
right.
You're so God damn naive that you know,
if evil ever popped out and made a face
at you,
which would likely will.
You'd be scared into posttraumatic
stress disorders so fast.
You wouldn't know what hit you.
And I've seen that plenty of times in my
clinical practice.